[Music]
before we talk about your beautiful
performance which was very very powerful
and stunning I want to talk about this
well you you feel it's like when you
hear a song you said this is a song for
me
this is a dress that I want to wear and
this dress with that performance with
the chandelier in that moment I mean it
was it was really really perfect I
thought that it was a drop in my sound
and they said no it's because the people
you had the biggest choir in the whole
wide world you you were you were they
were singing with all of you it's a
group it was a retention how did you see
that performance of your mom out there I
was awesome very special I mean very
emotional a special moment I was
actually right right behind the stage of
the golf ball I'm rusty I've only played
like I'm gonna tie in a couple months so
we're getting there hopefully hopefully
I think this y'all be scrappy but I know
your your your golf partner for many
years of course was your dad and it was
my dad's the one who got me into golf
back in the day is that how it worked
for you yeah I really that I remember I
was like see pictures I was 2 3 years
old going at the range like every day
pinball so played a couple holders
really awesome wouldn't you start
singing not only I have the voice for it
I got a chance to speak with Rene
Charles a little bit and he was watching
you he called your performance powerful
and then I also asked him as a golfer
myself how his golf games doing and I
said he got his golf game from his dad
and maybe his singing voice from you
he's into music into he's great in
school I have to admit it and talk about
that but I'm very proud of him he's into
music he loves it he's into golf and
he's into hockey as well
you